now imagine yourself working as a
front-end web developer you've just
gotten a design from your company's
graphic designer
and you now need to take this image or
PDF file and turn it into a website with
all of the necessary components HTML
files CSS files and JavaScript files but
how do you translate that visual design
into an actual website right where do
you start what decisions do you have to
make what you need to know and these are
like excellent questions asked but
before we do that we should probably
build a good conceptual understanding of
the way websites work yep exactly
so you can think of a website much like
your house HTML files are like the
structure where are the walls placed
what room is your living room what room
is your kitchen which room is your
bedroom CSS files are then the style of
your house what color is the carpeting
what decorations do you have up what
color are the walls JavaScript files are
then your interactive components you can
think of them like your garage door
opener or your television remote they're
changing some element of your house now
much like there are rules for how things
in your house behave you can't have a
television that's just floating on the
wall it has to be attached by something
there are also rules for how websites
behave the same goes for tools
you can't put together a bookshelf for
example without a screwdriver and there
are also many web tools available to
help you build your websites it's a
great point I love this analogy it's an
awesome analogy what do you say we get
started in learning some of the basics
sounds great